Jonathan Weiner is next on book TV with
a story of Jamie Heywood and a search
for a cure for his brother Stephen who
was diagnosed with Lou Gehrig's disease
at the age of 28 his brother's keeper is
the new book this program lasts an hour
and a half I'm Pam Wayne and a program
coordinator with the Smithsonian
associates and I welcome you to this
evening lecture on top titled on the
edge of Medicine his brother's keeper by
Jonathan Weiner for those of you who
have not attended our events before I
encourage you to speak to one of the
monitors stationed outside after the
event about membership we offer a number
of programs in all fields for families
performing arts and for adults as well
as travel programs so we have some
literature that we'd be happy to share
with you if you're interested as I
mentioned tonight jonathan weiner
science writer and recent winner of the
pulitzer prize for general fiction
dramatically conveys the coming together
of major scientific efforts such as
cloning genomics molecular genetics
genetic engineering and embryonic stem
cell research to tell the story dr.
Weiner draws on the lives of two amazing
brothers Stephen Heywood a carpenter who
discovers he has Lou Gehrig's disease
and Jamie Heywood an engineer who quits
his lucrative job to start a foundation
dedicated to finding a cure Jonathan
Weiner is a visiting or was a visiting
professor in the department of molecular
biology at Princeton University where he
had taught since 1996 while reading this
book by while writing this
he was resident scholar and writer at
Rockefeller University in 1998 he served
as the McGraw professor of writing in
Princeton's Council for the Humanities
dr. Weiner when the Pulitzer Prize for
general nonfiction and the Los Angeles
Times Book Prize for science for his
book the beak of the Finch he is also
the author a planet Earth the companion
book to an Emmy award-winning PBS
television series and time love money
which explores the subject of behavioral
genetics his writing has appeared in The
New Yorker New York Times naturalist and
Washington Post as mentioned tonight
professor Weiner discusses the lives of
two amazing brothers is betrayed in his
new book which is available for signing
after the lecture so please join me in
welcoming Jonathan Weiner to the
Smithsonian associates
thank you very much Pam for that nice
introduction thank all of you for coming
tonight it's it's exactly 10 years I
think since I was here at the
Smithsonian speaking about my book the
beak of the Finch so it's a particular
pleasure to be invited back to the
Smithsonian to speak about my new book
his brother's keeper I've heard it said
that in Genesis Cain's question to to
God am I my brother's keeper as the
first question in scripture asked of God
in anger and that the whole of Scripture
can be interpreted as an attempt to
answer that question am I my brother's
keeper is a question that points us
toward the most profound ethical
questions we can ask about our
responsibilities of one to another and
today medicine and the challenges of
medicine where science meets medicine
and science begins to alter the promises
and also the perils of medicine is one
of the most ethically charged one of the
most fascinating one of the most intense
areas going on planet Earth i I've been
drawn to it for the last 10 years since
writing the beak of the Finch and I've
been drawn again and again to that edge
where science meets and informs medicine
because here more than anyplace else I
think science comes close to home for
all of us the way the human genome
project has vitalized and begun to
transform our hopes for medicine with
our hopes for personalized genomics
personalized medicine
our enormous hopes now for gene therapy
in the future stem cells somewhere in
the future all of that also threatens us
the hope comes with a certain amount of
fear and the ethical questions become
extremely intense especially here in
Washington and I want to talk a little
bit about the politics of these
questions as well it's been said that
going back to Genesis that the great
symbol now of science and also of
medicine is the double helix and it's
often compared in in a way that sort of
expresses our sense of sacred hope and
possibility and and also some danger in
it to the vision that Jacob had in the
desert when he laid his head on those
pillows of stone and dreamed and saw a
ladder and on that ladder angels
ascending and descending this is a
vision of science before us now and as a
friend of mine andrew Berry a science
writer who's here tonight has put it
surely the great question about those
angels ascending and descending and all
of us with them now is are we going to
go up where are we going to go down in
this century as science helps us to
transform our hopes and fears with
medicine well as I said ten years ago I
was here speaking about a very different
project I was speaking about the work of
Peter and Rosemary grant of Princeton
who go to the Galapagos Islands every
year and watch Darwin's finches evolve
and I'm struck how greatly science has
has advanced in its ability to look
inside those finches now and see what's
going on at the molecular level that
corresponds to the dramatic evolutionary
changes that Darwin inferred when he
looked at those finches back in the
nineteen in 19th century and that Peter
and Rosemary grant have been able to
follow generation by generation on a
desert island called Daphne major in the
center of the archipelago now it's
possible as it wasn't even ten years ago
to try to look at what makes the genetic
difference that changes the shape of the
beak of the Finch when I started the
book I hope that I would be able to
write that story and just to pick on
Andrew one more time I hung around in a
laboratory in which andrew worked at
Princeton a dozen years ago because
Peter and Rosemary grant were hoping to
do molecular studies to figure out what
goes on at the level of the genes in
order to transform the finches and that
work was just a little too soon to
happen a dozen years ago so I wasn't
able to talk about it in the book and
now it becomes quite possible using
little little blood samples that the
grants collect from the finches when
they make their measurement measurements
of the birds it becomes possible to look
at the changes in the DNA that are
driving evolution in that origin of
origins in the Galapagos Islands
Darwin's islands with Darwin's finches
after following the story of evolution
in the Galapagos in the beak of the
Finch I decided to look closer at the
changes in DNA that we all register in
our in our lives to look at differences
in DNA that can correspond to
differences in behavior and that curate
that question led me to follow the work
of Seymour Benzer at Caltech who does
extraordinary studies of fruit flies
which is as much as the Galapagos a
point of origin for a great deal of
biology today as you know a lot of
genetics in the 20th century culminating
in in DNA and then most recently in the
human genome project came out of the fly
bottle Morgan's fly bottles at the turn
of the 20th
entry well Seymour Benzer was a
physicist during World War Two a young
physicist who turn to molecular biology
shortly after the war as many physicists
did and helped to remake the science of
life almost in the image of physics by
focusing at the molecular level and see
more when he had kids became interested
in this question what makes us so
different one to the next at the level
of the genes this his first kid was very
Placid from the first week in the crib
his second daughter was very lively from
her first week in the crib and he
thought dotty and I aren't doing
anything all that different that these
kids are so different from their first
days on the earth what makes the
difference must be somewhere in the
genes that my friends Watson and Crick
and Sydney Brenner and a few other
pioneers have been working on I'm going
to look and try to find those
differences and benzer chose the fruit
fly because it was one of the wells the
well-studied best studied animals for
genetics and because it did have a
certain repertoire of behavior are flies
it sort of amuses us to think applies as
having even brains let alone behavior
but they do flies do a little courtship
dance for instance these fruit flies go
through a sort of Fred Astaire Ginger
Rogers routine when they meet and they
don't have to be taught it in dancing
school the male fly knows just how to
raise its wing and what sort of make
sort of a Bronx cheer of a song to make
right by trembling its wing as it
waltzes around the female and the female
is very sharp at distinguishing a good
dancer and a good singer from a bad one
and also at noticing differences in the
rhythm of the the male flies song and
dance and if the if the Flies got a
lousy sense of rhythm it doesn't get
anywhere with the female fly because a
slightly different rhythm can connote
the wrong species of fly and set and so
a waste of time according and mating
well
the study of the sense of time in the
fly provided a way into the mechanics of
behavior at the genetic and the
molecular level and it's astonishing
again in just in the last five years how
the study of time if you're in biology
you've been reading paper and paper
about this is exploding now it was put
on the map by Seymour Benzer literally
who with a grad student named Ron
Konopka found the first sense of time
gene the first clock gene which they
called period and it's now possible to
do startling experiments one of them
which I described in time of memory is
to extract with the tools of genetic
engineering the gene period from one
species of fly and give it to another
species that has normally a different
sense of rhythm and when that
genetically engineered fly begins to try
to court females it's singing the wrong
song and it's singing the wrong dance
and it can only attract a simulans when
it's really after a milana gaster it's
that kind of genetic engineering at the
level of at the level of behavior that I
think leads us in our imaginations of
the future near or far too some of what
scares us and some of what makes us
wonder if we're going up or down the
ladder in this in this new century of
the science of life and memory work the
study of genes that affect memory have
also been mushrooming in in the last
five years in fact two of the heroes of
time love memory who studied memory
genes at the time I met them have now
founded companies I think one of them is
called memory pharmaceuticals and
they're ardently searching for drugs
based on those genes that can help to
enhance our memories they could be of
enormous use to us they could also as
mind and
memory and personality altering drugs be
of some threat to our sense of identity
in the future and so again that that
sense of ethical conundrums that sense
of doubleness of a of a ladder of life
that goes up or down is before us well
having followed this progression over
the last the last 10 years or so from
the study of life at the traditional
19th century level that Peter and
rosemary were doing on in the Galapagos
watching Darwin's finches evolved to the
studies that were central to the advance
of the 20th century at in jeans and at
the molecular level and seeing how it
was all leading toward toward human
experience I wanted to follow a story
that would take us right there that
would come as close to home as it was
possible to come and I found it in the
story of two brothers just outside
Boston Jamie and Stephen Heywood Pam
Wayman in her introduction awarded me
the Pulitzer for fiction and I want to
say that this is all non fiction as my
other books are and that Jamie and
Stephen are real people in fact this is
this is the British edition of the book
which is just out but it has the same
photograph of the two brothers and this
is jamie and this is stephen there there
handsome enough guys to be to be models
or actors and people looking at the book
have asked me if if if those really are
the brothers and in fact they are I want
to read to you the the introductory page
or two from the book and then talk about
the story and how it brings the edge of
medicine so close to home
chapter one portents when they were boys
Jamie and Stephen hey would love to
arm-wrestle they made it a ritual first
the right arm then the left then if
there was time a wrestling match on the
rug their rules of engagement were so
complicated and so long unspoken that no
one else ever learned the game even
Jamie's best friend Duncan moss did not
know how to play Duncan would take one
step across the line on the road then he
would see the look on Jamie's face what
what did I do he did not know the rules
the heywoods lived in an old house on
mill street in newtonville Massachusetts
a suburb of Boston all three of the
Heywood boys Jamie then Stephen and then
the youngest Ben were athletic dreamers
inventors of many rituals and inventors
and adventures the house on mill street
is a block from a patch of woods and
upon the brothers played football there
in a corner field by the house of a
neighbor they called aunt Betsy late at
night when it rained hard Jamie and
Stephen snuck out with boogie boards
they hopped a fence to the creep which
got roaring in a good storm through the
dark and the rain they rode the rapids
out of bolos pond their parents Peggy
and John Heywood are well known in
newtonville they loved traditions to
each of them has served terms as senior
warden of grace church in newton corner
when their boys were young they went
back every summer to the dairy farm in
South Dakota where Peggy had grown up
she had won a full scholarship to
Radcliffe in Cambridge which is where
she met John Peggy worked as a therapist
she kept her practice small and devoted
herself to the family every seven years
they spent a year in England where John
was born and raised John Heywood is a
professor of mechanical engineering at
the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology and an international
authority on internal combustion engines
he is the son of a British cold engineer
who turned to solar power early on
back when only the cranks were
interested in what he had to say John
Heywood consults about energy efficiency
for Ford in Detroit Ferrari and Italy
toyota in japan in japan when he is at
home he runs MIT sloan automotive
laboratory to which he commutes to Mill
Street on a bicycle each summer in July
or August Peggy side of the family
gathered from across the country for a
reunion at the beach town of duck near
Kitty Hawk in the Outer Banks of North
Carolina a few of the children on the
beach were always honorary Heywood's as
Aunt Betsey was an honorary aunt John
and Peggy Jamie Stephen and Ben each
brought friends the boys swam sailed
surfed and raced on the cold shining
track the waves made for them every
summer on one of their last days at duck
they played a game of basketball at the
beach wickedly violent games that
routinely sent one of their cousins to
the hospital as Jamie and Stephen got
older by the way that was one cousin
they told me later it was always the
same cousin as Jamie and Stephen got
older they kept armwrestling ritually in
their late teens and early 20s when the
two and a half years between them no
longer mattered they were perfectly
matched but Jamie became a mechanical
engineer like their father and his
father in England Jamie was intelligent
and driven and spent his days and nights
working at a desk Stephen became a
carpenter a hands-on man like their
mother's father and brother and South
Dakota Stephen was intelligent too but
he mistrusted desks and ambitions he
spent a few years swinging a hammer on a
framing crew and his right arm became
unbeatable late in july of 1997 when
jamie was 30 and Stephen was 28 they arm
wrestled in the beach house their
parents had rented that summer at duck
Jamie was five feet eleven and
three-quarter inches tall and he weighed
165 pounds Stephen was six foot three
220
Jamie was keeping himself in shape but
Stephen was building his first house
that year and his right bicep and tricep
were very well defined in arm wrestling
there's always a moment when the winner
knows he is one and the loser knows he's
lost the brothers were both surprised
when they realized that for the first
time in five years Jamie would force
Stephens right arm down to the table
Jamie woot I beat my carpenter brother
I'm the man I'm the man steven won the
next bout which they fought as always
left-handed that shut up Jamie neither
of them suspected that anything was
wrong that was 1997 at that time I
hadn't yet met the Heywood's and I was
following the birth announcement of
dolly I was buying that story which took
place that year 97 and I still remember
the tremendous excitement and also the
tremendous alarm that went up around the
time of the the cloning of that first
lamb in Scotland I went to a lecture at
Princeton that a molecular biologist Lee
silver was giving he was writing a book
about the possibilities of
transformation of infertility clinics
transformation of reproduction generally
for the human species by the new biology
and he brought the manuscript with him
to the talk and he lifted it over his
head and he tore it up in front of us
and he said anything is now possible
anything is possible now 1997 it was a
time when tremendous hopes were rising
for technology generally stocks were
rising like crazy in silica you know
Silicon Valley nasty
that was all shooting up our hopes for
Biotechnology were rising Stephen
Haywood as it happened was in a
wonderful position as a carpenter
building his first house that year
because he was building in Palo Alto
which is prime Silicon Valley and the
house a little cottage that he had
bought for a song as is no questions
asked and then refinished and
reconstructed with tremendous loving
care was was now looking to be worth a
fortune if he could get it finished he
kept slipping his deadlines one after
the other his whole family by the end of
nineteen ninety-seven went out to the
house to help him with the work John
Heywood took a sabbatical from MIT and
went out there to write a book about
engines and also to help out Stephen
with the carpentry Peggy retired from
her work as a psychotherapist in order
to make the trip with John been the
youngest of the Haywood boys was
collaborating with Stephen as business
partner he was taking some time out
before Stanford Business School and
planning hoping to become a producer in
Hollywood and Jamie Haywood the older
the oldest of the three Heywood boys was
there as often as he could get in order
to help out Jamie at the end of nineteen
ninety-seven caught up hardly caught up
entirely but this was only one of the
reasons he changed careers but caught up
in the spirit of the hope for
Biotechnology had decided to switch
careers leave mechanical engineering
leave his work as an entrepreneurial
engineer and go to work in a think tank
in California called the neurosciences
Institute it's in la jolla it's run by a
Nobel prize-winning immunologist and now
neuroscientist named Gerald Adelman and
they needed a young whiz kid to help
them turn their ideas which were always
at the far edge of science into into
possibly into therapies possibly into
money making projects that could be
creating profits they could plow back
into their nonprofit research at the
Institute so they hired Jamie at the end
of 97 to join the neurosciences
Institute and for Christmas week he was
at the house to one day that week this
is what four or five months after the
arm wrestling at duck Steven went up to
the front door he had noticed that the
locks were sticking in the house the
front door lock the side lot the back
door all the lots were sticking but that
wasn't particularly a surprise because
he had put in all of this stuff and he
hadn't had a chance to fine-tune it yet
it was top of the line it was brass and
it would need only a little tinkering he
was sure to make it work so the front
door the key stuck and he thought today
I'm going to deal with this he took the
lock apart he checked to make sure that
everything was aligned he put it back
together everything was aligned he tried
again to turn the key in the key would
not turn and then experimentally maybe
far in the back of his mind remembering
the armwrestling that summer he tried
the key with his left hand and with his
left hand the key turn smoothly in the
lock and then he tried again with his
right and with his right hand standing
at the door of the first house he had
built the house that he hoped would be
the first in a very long line of houses
he could not turn the key after the
house was sold in the spring of 98 for
almost a million dollars profit a gross
profit of something like three hundred
percent Stevens still hoping that he was
on a path toward a new career a path
toward a career he sort of prided
himself himself on being the slacker of
this very bright family up
that point now he had a sense of what he
really wanted to do with his life he
went to see a doctor about the weakness
in his right hand and the doctor sent
him to a specialist who sent him to
another who sent him to another and it
wasn't until the end of that year the
end of 98 that Steven having now moved
in moved back to newtonville moved into
his parents house concerned about a
growing weakness in his right arm left
Massachusetts General Hospital after six
hours of very grueling nerve conduction
tests got into his car drove down Starro
drive backward toward newtonville and
picked up his parents borrowed cell
phone and with his first call called
Jamie hey would his older brother at the
neurosciences Institute and he said well
it doesn't look good there's weakness in
all four limbs they said very little the
two brothers were trying to be
unflappable but by then they knew enough
to know exactly what that news meant
even though the formal diagnosis had not
yet been pronounced the spread of that
weakness in the in the arm the tests
that had ruled out other other more
benign possibilities meant that almost
certainly he had ALS Lou Gehrig's
disease known in England as motor neuron
disease a terrible disease that
essentially meant he had only a few
years to live Jamie knew immediately
what it meant and as soon as he hung up
he turned back to his computer screen
kept his office at the Institute and he
typed the words ALS prognosis and he
began searching for hours to find out
more about the prognosis for his brother
which was uniformly grim no matter where
he looked and hoping to find perhaps
some glimmer of a hope that there was
something on her
that might be able to turn this
incurable disease into a curable one in
time to save his brother he soon
realized that he had if he wanted to
save his brother which he discovered he
desperately did he had only he had no
time at all in which to do it because if
he wanted to save Stephen while Stephen
was still as extraordinarily athletic
and fit as as he was then in 98 he had
to come up with a plan he had to come up
with a an idea for a cure and then he
had to find the experts to implement
that cure all in the matter of months
because Stephen was likely to be
declining very rapidly and be stuck in a
wheelchair within another year or so and
astonishingly Jamie resolved as I think
very few of us very few of us would have
the he calls it the MIT the techie
hubris to do Jamie resolved that he was
going to do just that he was going to
save his brother no matter what it took
and he was he was quite confident that
he'd be able to do it two days after
getting the call from Stephen he he
resigned from the neurosciences
Institute he gave notice he said he'd be
leaving in two months to go back home to
newtonville he and his wife Melinda
would be leaving La Jolla and moving
back in with John and Peggy in
newtonville along with Stephen and
Stevens girlfriend and and Jamie would
be saving his brother it was it was one
month after that that I got a call from
a neuroscientist friend of mine at the
Institute a guy named Ralph Greenspan
Ralph had told me about Seymour Benzer
and his work on jeans and behavior and
that Brooke time love memory which Ralph
had led me to had just come out in fact
I had it propped up on my desk when
Ralph call because when a book first
comes out
if any of you have had this experience
you know you know what it's like you're
really just sort of in mobile you're
just counting the fingers and toes and
staring at this newborn book for four
hours so I had it propped up there and
Ralph called and he said have I got a
story for you so I said well that would
make two and he said no this one he said
would be a little more compelling and
and a lot more poignant and he told me
the story of Jamie's race now to save
his brother and he told me that
astonishingly enough in the matter of a
month since the call from from Steven
Jamie had hit on an idea and I should
tell you that Jamie was not a biologist
I've mentioned he was a mechanical
engineer he had not even taken a course
in biology at MIT he'd been absolutely
focused on engineering until making that
switch to the neurosciences Institute a
year before and he's a quick study but
he was still very much an outsider and
yet even as an outsider he had managed
to come up with an idea that was
promising and that was interesting to to
Ralph Greenspan who was a very
discriminating guy a scientist with good
taste and Ralph told me a little bit
about it Jamie was planning a gene
therapy in order to try to save his
brother and he was moving back to try to
put together a dream a dream team of
scientists to implement that gene
therapy well I called Jamie and I spoke
with him on the phone very briefly he
sounded absolutely exhausted and he also
sounded so so brave in a to me very very
young and very husky exhausted voice he
told me that he had just gotten back
from another trip to to Boston this is
februari he said typical pissing boston
weather and seeing his family and he was
he was packing up and preparing to go
back and quite determined
well Ralph could not have known when he
called me just how close to home this
story was coming I was very moved to
hear it as all of us as any of us would
be but at the same time I immediately
thought of my parents who live an hour
away from newtonville in Providence
Rhode Island my father happens to be a
professor of engineering like John
Heywood at Brown University my mother
had been sick in a mysterious disturbing
with this disturbing sort of sweet of
undiagnosable symptoms for some years
and just at that time in February of 98
she had begun to stumble and fall in a
very scary way out of the blue she would
suddenly as if the strings of a
marionette had been cut or dropped she
would just suddenly collapsed to the
floor not know why and have no memory of
having fallen it was clear by now that
there was something seriously wrong and
that it was some sort of but
neurological or neurodegenerative
disease and so listening to Jamie's
response to to the crisis and his family
I felt an overwhelming interest not only
in what he might find but also in the
response itself that he wasn't accepting
the unknown he wasn't accepting the
known the the verdict that the death was
now inevitable for his brother he wasn't
accepting any of it and he was setting
out to change change the course of the
future for his brother and for his
family so I decided that I would write
an article for The New Yorker magazine a
profile of Jamie and Stephen I would
follow their story and I would learn
something about the way the edge of
medicine works when we come close to or
even go over the edge into the
unknown the way that feels for those of
us right at the edge and and also that I
might pick up something that could have
the most practical importance for my for
my parents and Providence it seemed at
the outset to me like a very simple
poignant heroic and just a brave
adventurer it it got complicated very
quickly and i'll tell you a little bit
about that with the with the with
enormous ethical ethical confusions and
complexities graham greene once said in
an interview that he could pick one
epigraph for all of his novels and and
that would be a line from Robert
Browning our interests in the dangerous
edge of things well this story leads us
to the dangerous edge of things and as
simple as it seemed that that in the
beginning one brother reaching reaching
for the other trying to draw another
breath back from the underworld it also
became in some ways as gray and complex
as one of graham greene's
entertainment's I met Jamey I began
talking with Jamie in the in the early
spring of 98 soon after he got back to
the two to Boston in the East Coast and
I was astonished at the speed with which
he was able to put together his dream
team he managed to enlist the help of
Jeff Rothstein a leading ALS researcher
at Johns Hopkins University who had
published a paper arguing that a key
problem in ALS one of the common
denominators may be the key common
denominator in all these bewilder in
cases
als is that one particular protein is
malformed the protein is called EA 82
often pronounced eat24 short what Jamie
had decided to do as his gene therapy
was to find a gia gene therapist to
genetically engineer a good version of
the e to gene and to get a neurosis and
a neurosurgeon to help the gene
therapist to inject that good gene into
Stevens spine where the motor nerves are
dying in ALS what happens the reason the
british call it motor neuron disease is
that the motor nerves which are the
nerves that run up and down the spine
the nerves that carry messages from the
brain to the rest of the body that tell
tell the foot to lift or tell the hand
to turn a key in a door those nerves the
motor nerves begin to die one by one for
reasons nobody understands and as they
go the brain becomes increasingly cut
off from the body increasingly enfeebled
unable remaining just as clear and just
as strong-willed as ever but unable to
lift the foot or to move the hand
eventually those muscles because they
aren't being commanded to move by the
brain begin to waste away and the body
becomes emaciated the body becomes
increasingly weak the victim of ALS is
able to watch all this with a perfectly
clear mind and understanding as the body
just fades away and in the end after
several years sometimes after four or
five a victim of ALS is no longer strong
enough to breathe and needs breathing
assistance and then after a time even
that isn't enough and people with ALS
often eventually suffocate or they choke
to death it's a terrible disease it's a
it's a disease about which there's
almost nothing good one
say even the gift of the clear mind is a
doubtful gift in a situation like that
well if eat to was defective and if that
defect was somehow causing those motor
neurons to die then the engineering
solution that Jamie saw very clearly
before him was to get that gene into
those motor neurons encased in Stephen
spinal cord and to persuade the
surviving nerves and cells surrounding
the nerves to make good eat too because
if they could make good eat too then
perhaps he could save the rest of the
nerves in the in the bundled nerves and
the sort of cable inside the spinal
column from death and keep Steven from
losing any more of his strength so Jeff
Rothstein at Hopkins found this idea
provocative and exciting he himself was
excited about eat too but it had never
occurred to him to jump immediately
toward gene therapy that was an
out-of-the-box idea and Jamie managed to
enlist the help of an extraordinarily a
pioneering and adventurous gene
therapist who was then at Jefferson
Medical College in Philadelphia Matthew
during I happen to live just outside
Philadelphia in Bucks County so that
again brought the story close to home
and I was able to go and visit Matt
during and i think it was in my first
visit to during slab that I wast
whatever a distance I had still
preserved in following this story I was
beginning to get so caught up by now in
the lives of Jamie and Stephen and John
and Peggy and Jamie and Stephens wives
well Melinda and Stephen his
then-girlfriend although they were very
early on engaged Stevens Stephens next
act after talking to Jamie was to call
Wendy and almost two more or less to
propose I guess although i don't know
the
act details of that conversation they
were moved immediately to accelerate
what was already a love story for them
that fall and to to her eat or talk of
marriage and talk of children so things
were happening very fast for Steven
things were happening very fast for
Jamie and I couldn't help but watch not
just as a reporter but also as what
began to feel role almost as an honorary
Haywood well when I went to visit Matt
during I met somebody who was a lot like
Jamie Heywood a a guy with a very
adventurous spirit a guy who was willing
to be known as a cowboy something of a
cowboy in a maverick to others someone
who was willing to offend the people who
he saw is as working inside the box and
an in fact Matt during and his then
count colleague paulo leone were
extremely controversial people in the
field of gene therapy they had kind of
gone from one controversy to another but
they did very good work and i said i
talked with Matt and Matt's a response
when I told him that I had a more than
professional interest in our the subject
of our conversation that my mother also
had a neurodegenerative disease then by
then diagnosed as Lewy body dementia I
offered to come up with an experimental
therapy to treat my mother too yeah and
at that point no normally when I'm
interviewing I've got a notebook out I'm
scribbling away sometimes I have a tape
recorder going at the same time as I did
then I stopped scribbling notes I let
the tape recorder roll and I felt for
the first time the full extent of the
responsibility that Jamie had assumed
for his brother the thought that I might
now be talking to someone who could
actually save my mother from what we had
been told was an incurable disease that
I might be giving the word if my father
agreed that I might be urging my mother
to undergo a dangerous treatment at the
dangerous edge of things that could
hasten her death rather than cure her of
the Lewy body dementia that was very
present to my mind as well and I
remember walking through the laboratory
on the standard sort of tour that you
get after meeting meeting gay laboratory
scientists and staring at a mouse that
was anesthetized on and operating a very
small operating table in which gene
therapy techniques were being practiced
and just feeling almost an hallucination
and also hard that was completely mind
stopping for me I mean I almost couldn't
think anymore imagining not even wanting
to imagine that I might be placing a
loved one in in the position of that
that laboratory creature in and and
undergoing the very same experimental
treatment and in effect asking my mother
to to be a laboratory rat in what was
more likely than not to prove to be a
very small step in the progress of
medicine rather than an operation that
would save her Jamie had been able to
make that leap instantly the moment he
hung up the god of the phone from from
the call with Stephen he had assumed
that responsibility and I felt it as as
just overwhelming and I think also at
that moment I realized that although
anyone who sets out to be a writer has
sort of a
heroic self image I mean in some way
it's the Clark Kent and Superman
dichotomy you have a sense of inner
heroism that drives you the writer were
to paint or whatever it is you do I'd
always sort of felt like some sort of
secret hero expressing that in the
writing and I realized that I am NOT a
hero at all cuz I really found this an
overwhelming overwhelming situation and
when I went back to Providence it hit me
that the question the real key question
in that decision our home decision had
to be my mother's wishes and yet my
mother at that moment had begun a
precipitous decline and it was almost
simultaneous with Matt Doering zhou fir
it became impossible for us even to hope
to ask her wishes there was no way that
she could have comprehended the question
anymore and we realized very quickly
that she was past saving so my focus
turned back completely to Jamie's race
to save Stephen and it was now deepened
by that experience of having felt the
weight on my shoulders that Jamie had to
be feeling on his the summer progressed
with an extraordinary sense of
acceleration summer of 99 again the
whole world was in an enormously felt
like the whole world was in an
enormously optimistic mood about the
future of biology advances in
biomedicine it seemed as if tremendous
revolutionary advances were right around
the corner the human genome project was
was accelerating toward its conclusion
we would soon have all of our genes on a
disk we would have every single letter
of the genetic code all strung out three
billion letters of them we would have
some sort of answers that we could apply
to any kind of question we we might pose
including the curing of the incurable
and
day Jamie's experiments were going well
he was helping to supervise the project
at Jeff Ross teens that have been in
Matt the map during slab in Philadelphia
shuttling back and forth stopping now
and then in Doylestown to to meet me and
meet my family for dinner as if he was
just in the neighborhood and then you
know after a long and very convivial
dinner he would say so long and he would
drive another five six hours back up to
Boston and then he'd be up first thing
in the morning early in the morning and
and putting in another 20-hour day and
that was the way he was working
continuing it was while I was visiting
the heywoods in early September of 99
that in retrospect our hopes reached
their their Apogee Jamie got a call an
ecstatic call from Jeff Rothstein at
Hopkins who had gone to a neurosciences
meeting and had bumped into a young
neuro scientist who was performing a
little experiment that they'd been very
curious to hear the results of for
months and months what this young
researcher had done rather casually she
was interested in epilepsy not in ALS
but she had gotten a small number of ALS
mice mice that have been read
genetically engineered to contract
symptoms that look very much like ALS
and the died very young I think within a
matter of within less than two months
these mice died paralyzed and choking in
their cages she had bred mice that made
too much eat two mice that made too much
of that protein that molecular machine
that's so crucial to the conduction of
signals down the spinal column from the
brain to the muscles in ALS patients
remember Rothstein's hypothesis was that
they don't make enough of it or they
make it badly where they make it in such
a way that it isn't able to reach its
intended post in the cell and as a
result those nerve cells begin to die
well these mites made too much eat too
so she had bred a mouse that made too
much eat too with an ALS mouse and and
had a litter of mice that were a cross
between those two and what Rothstein and
what Jamie Heywood were dying to know
not that it could ever be conclusive it
was only one little study in the corner
of this young researchers lab but they
were dying to know what happened if a
mouse that was going to die young of ALS
inherited the genes that that
manufactured too much eat too would it
come down with the disease what would
happen so well at that moment I was it
was evening I was talking with John
Heywood again I had the tape recorder
rolling John is both British engine and
an engineer so he has a very charming
reticence and and reserved and he was
speaking with as much composure as he
could master about the crisis that that
his family had plunged into that year
when the phone rang and then it rang
again in the kitchen and we just kept
talking through it but I realized that I
was hearing shouts on the answering
machine it was one of those answering
machines where you can hear the call
coming in and the shout was Jamie's
voice yelling dad pick up the phone dad
pick up the phone so eventually I said
John let's go let's go see what Jamie
wants and we went he was a few blocks
away in in the house that he and Melinda
had by now moved into with Stephen they
were playing some video games it was
boys night out and they play these
computer games with the computers side
by side and he had just gotten a call
from Roston and he said the mouse the
mouse that was supposed to be dead is
still alive bring John over here so John
Heywood drove me over we went over to
jamie's Jamie's house and old
orion kind of decrepit which stephen was
now plaintiff planning to fix up for for
his brother and his wife and four and
four he and Wendy when they got married
and and Jamie explained to us in kind of
ecstasy that one mouse just one Mouse in
that litter had inherited the 82 genes
from one parent and of course had the
ALS genes and all the other mouse in the
mice in the litter had died paralyzed
choking at a very young age and this
mouse they now knew was still alive and
it was 9 10 months old and it had lived
far beyond the lifespan of any other
mouse in the history of ALS mice it's
the oldest mouse in the history of ALS
Jamie was shouting well John Heywood a
seasoned scientist Ben and engineer kept
a very level head he said one mouse and
and Jamie just said yeah dad it's the
oldest mouse in the history of a lab did
this is huge Jeff Rothstein is jumping
up and down and that was it it was like
when when you watch at the end of a
basketball game and and somebody let's
lose this one incredible shot and it's
arcing and it's arcing at the top of its
arc you just convinced that that ball
was going in at that moment I think
almost all of us close to this project
following this project were convinced
that Jamie had somehow the force was
with him he had gotten the death star
the ball was going in and he was going
to save his brother what Jeff Ross teen
had not said on the phone because he
wanted to let the Heywood family enjoy
this this good piece of news before
passing on terrible news was that he had
also heard at the meeting at that same
meeting on the same day another very sad
piece of news a young man named Jesse
gelsinger had entered a gene therapy
trial also in Philadelphia just across
town from
from Stephens doctor from Matt during
laboratory at Jefferson and Jesse
gelsinger had died of the gene therapy
the trial had been as it turned out
misconceived in many ways the project
had been bungled and Gelsinger had died
because of the series partly because of
a series of mistakes that had been made
it caused a scandal here in Washington
it caused the national and even an
international scandal and gene therapy
projects like Jamie Heywood's and a
thousand others is just screeched to a
stance though
it was almost as if you know in as an
English major in college I learned about
something called pathetic fallacy which
is in writing a very often if something
good is happening writers will have the
sun shining and the weather beautiful
and if something terrible is happening
something tragic and awful is happening
well then there has to be an earthquake
where there has to be a terrible
thunderstorm you know the Gothic sorts
of clichés that's the pathetic fallacy
that the whole world follows our own
small lives and tragedies it felt that
way here because as Jamie's project ran
into serious serious trouble so did all
of those hopes for a sort of utopian
millennium millenarian revolution
arriving with the turn of the new
century the stock market the stock
market's hopes in Silicon Valley and
also in by a biotechnology crashed then
the towers came down and a tremendous
surge of optimism that we had all felt
and that for me Jamie Heywood's race had
had had symbolized veered into a very
different and very difficult time it was
for me watching the decline that that
Stephen began and watching the decline
continued in in my folks house in
Providence it was a very grim time and
it was a time in which out of out of I
think just personal grief more than
anything else I I I felt almost angry at
at the science and medicine that had
that had engaged and raised my hopes the
year before and I remember talking with
Shirley Tilghman a biologist friend at
Princeton who was now the president of
the University and a meeting from her
almost an expression of a larger faith
in scientific progress that even if it
doesn't come in time to save an
individual that one loves it is moving
forward and it is going to help and that
it is a good thing in spite of the
dangerous edges and in spite of the
darker possibilities that it brings that
was 44 for me and for the heywoods a
dark time uh I'm not going to say much
more about what happened next but I'm
happy to say that uh Jamie hey would
continue to to struggle to save Steven
that he continues to do that now and
that good things extraordinarily good
things although not quite as
extraordinary as we hoped and almost
expected in 99 are coming from that
group of people and others Jamie Heywood
has now built a research foundation in
Boston that is devoted entirely to a
sort of retro back to the past approach
to finding a cure for ALS he and a team
of technicians are testing fda-approved
drugs drugs that have already received
fda approval and therefore aren't going
to run into the sorts of red tape the
gene therapy projects and proposals
would they're testing them on
LS mice they're testing just sort of
ransacking the medicine cabinet for
anything that might conceivably based on
some new paper have a positive effect
and then they're testing them in
different cocktails and combinations
looking for even the smallest a life
extension for the ALS mice in fact when
I was talking to him recently
reminiscing about those early days in 99
when we were cheering on that ALS mouse
that had lived the mouse that had lived
and that Jamie in explaining how
exciting it was had said you don't
understand the big pharmaceutical houses
are spending millions tens of millions
hundreds of millions to try to find a
drug that could extend the life of these
mice by a day you know and this is
months and months and Jamie just laughed
hysterically and he said that's me now
I'm I'm looking for something that it
extended by a day or by a week because
those little increments can provide
enormous clues and Jeff Rothstein
continues to work exploring gene therapy
options and making enormous progress and
working on stem cells to with tremendous
tremendous optimism and that sort of
stoic strength that allows researchers
to carry on when they're enormously
caring in the in the clinic and when
they're losing patience not just
generation by generation but every year
every every day having to pronounce this
death sentence and every day having to
having to lose a patient and yet
carrying on with that extraordinary hope
so Rothstein is doing that map during is
working on stem cell approaches and
making making strides and the whole the
whole field I think of biomedicine which
is beginning to resume to surge again a
little bit in optimism is it is it's a
healthier optimism now it's a sort of
chase and hope it lacks that apocalyptic
millennial
anything is possible now mood that that
you felt if you were in the middle of it
in 98 99 but it is a more sober
expectation that the incredible advances
in understanding that we've seen in the
century of the gene the 20th century
will be transforming medicine in ways
that can cure the incurable in this
century having having dipped solo having
felt so low having felt so grimly that
the angels were descending on Jacob's
Ladder I want to say now in a moment of
a political decision in this country
that from the point of view of someone
who's watched this extraordinary
suffering that these neurodegenerative
diseases bring the benefits of
continuing with something like something
as promising as stem cell research and
continuing with all our wits about us
with all our caution and yet with all
our resources and all of our enterprise
our manifests are overwhelming it's a
scary thought to me that these diseases
that we call rare that we call orphan
diseases like ALS are in the same large
pool with very common neurodegenerative
diseases like Alzheimer's and
Parkinson's that in advance in any one
of them a cure for the rare disease
comparatively rare disease ALS might
provide a cure for Parkinson's that all
of our grain baby boom generation and
those ahead of us and those behind us
are if our society doesn't push toward
tremendous advances now in stem cell
research are liable to in effect be
orphaned by biomedicine that we're going
to need this
in other words we're going to need this
stuff very badly and from what I've seen
we can't expect the cures and the
answers to come in that one moment of
the forces with us and in Luke slaying
the Death Star it does take a buckling
down and an enormously patient effort
worldwide and where the national leaders
in that effort and we haven't been doing
our jobs certainly not with stem cells
over the last years of this
administration in fact biologists in
this country have felt awful they felt
that their hands were tied that they
weren't able to do the research they
needed to do some of it's been picked up
elsewhere although international
politics about stem cells are also
conflicted I think it would be a
horrible feeling in 20 years to find
that one was facing one of these
neurodegenerative diseases and that the
Cure wasn't there and that we had lost
it on account of a dangling Chad so I
want to make a pitch I don't normally
bring politics into these conversations
but it seems just here and now
inevitable that we should say we really
need to be sponsoring this research we
really need to have a government that is
behind our scientists and that is
pushing as hard as it can I see a hand
already raising and I hope I'm not going
to regret bringing politics into this
conversation but I want to say in
closing that I am continuing to write
about the dangerous edge of things at
the edge of medicine and about the
search for cures for neurodegenerative
diseases and that I've wondered
sometimes for those reading his his
brother's keeper whether they would find
the story to be dispiriting or inspiring
if they were on this quest and I'm happy
to say
at a neuroscientist I'm writing about
right now a man who's looking for cures
for for some of these very diseases had
just read the book and he said what a
what a hopeful and inspiring example and
I came away with with the tremendous
energy and I'm glad I I would as complex
as the story is and I tried to do some
justice to the complexities that I saw
in it as it unfolded I hope that it is a
story that that inspires and and
following the heywoods has inspired me
and I want to close with the quote that
that this guy I'm writing about uses as
as as his own personal epigraph it's
it's from cow Moos the plague and it
describes a moment a sort of moment asus
if Ian moment in which the doctor
realizes that after his enormous efforts
the plague has lifted from the city and
the future is looking better for the
city nonetheless kemah rights he knew
that the tale he had to tell could not
be one of a final victory it could be
only the record of what had to be done
and what assuredly would have to be done
again in the never-ending fight against
terror and its relentless onslaught
despite the personal afflictions by all
who while unable to be Saints but
refusing to bow down to pestilence
strive their utmost to be healers thank
you very much
thanks for
yes we have a question thank you so much
my name is Hillary Robinson and I
started college in 1999 which was the
year that the the human genome project
became a race to decode and I sort of
thereby decided that I would study not
only government but molecular biology as
well and then having graduated last
spring I decided that instead of medical
school I would go to law school so I've
constantly thought that sort of politics
or the world of law will have to be
lockstep with the scientific
advancements and interestingly you know
you gave sort of a wonderful plug for
changing administration policies with
regard to science but at the same time
you've characterized this edge of
medicine as dangerous and I wanted to
push a little bit on why it's dangerous
because it occurs to me that the
distinction is between what we're told
by the scientific establishment of the
medical establishment and what we can
conceive of which is really captured by
your book the conception that your
mother could be that Mouse and that
occurs to us or at least in your
perception is dangerous and I'm
wondering if it's fear of death that
makes it dangerous because presumably
fear of death is what brought us to the
edge in the first place and how that you
know in light of the plug that you gave
at the end which i think is great how
you sort of reconcile those two things
which I personally had difficulty doing
but wanted to speak both languages in
order to reconcile it for other people
so far as understanding the science and
the law and being able to sort of make
things go forward in a legal way so i
would i'd appreciate your thoughts i
think it's wonderful that you're putting
both of those interests together that
way
we need people who are going to be
versed in the law and versed in science
and that's just fantastic I I spoke of
the dangerous edge of medicine and gave
only a few examples of the sorts of
dangers that I i saw in following this
story and others one of them as you say
was the danger that one enters in having
to make decisions of like this which are
life life or death decisions do you want
personally to enroll in a clinical trial
that might advance medicine but I might
not do you any good and in fact might do
you yourself harm those sorts of
questions were on my mind watching
Jamie's race to save Stephen um in a
different sort of way it was clear that
my mother couldn't possibly make such a
decision and we didn't feel in the
family that we could enroll her in a
dangerous trial because I didn't I I
couldn't be sure she would have wanted
to do that herself and because as I said
she was already past saving by the time
the decision came Stephen was a
perfectly clear that he wanted to go
ahead with with what might have been a
very dangerous operation they were about
to apply for permission to the FDA when
on kgehlsen jurors death created this
enormous scandal here in Washington made
it almost impossible to advance with
gene therapy trials but it was going to
be a scary operation it was going to
involve a going through the throat the
neuroscientist neurosurgeon was going to
have to open Stevens throat from the
front and and inject the virus that
would carry the good eat two genes into
his spinal column and Jeff Rothstein at
Hopkins was telling me this is a very
dangerous procedure this is very scary
now steven is a smart guy and he's
perfectly capable of making up his own
mind but I was scared watching and I
wondered whether in his position in love
getting married with his beloved older
brother racing having turned his own
life upside down in order to to offer
this to Steven whether Steven had full
free on a freedom of consent whether he
could really look at it clearly and I
talked with the herald shapiro at that
time the head of the National the
presidential bioethics Commission about
that question he chaired a commission
just then about patient consent and he
helped to reassure me that the right
thing in a situation like that really is
to talk to the patient and let the
patient decide and that he would never
want to be so paternal or presumptuous
he said as to tell someone in Stevens
position that he couldn't go ahead if he
wanted to there were other complexities
that made me uneasy in which I talk
about in the in the book but didn't have
time to mention here a one that bothered
me I think partly because I was coming
from more the old-fashioned biology the
more naturalist's biology was the money
question at one point early on after I
had decided to write about Jamie and
Steven and Jamie's quest Jamie began
debating with himself and with me
whether it might be right to start a
biotech company if eat to was going to
be the answer it was going to be worth a
fortune and maybe he could make an
enormous profit maybe he could have it
all continue to be the entrepreneur he
had been before he started and make a
fortune for himself Steven was certainly
going to need money and and at the same
time save his brother
as the guy following this story with an
exclusive inside roll on I worried
sometimes that I was going to bring the
new yorker magazines a seal of approval
to a start-up and was it well founded
and would it lead to good things and I
felt again a sense of responsibility I
think in a sense of danger I think now
looking back at it part of my uneasiness
there wasn't so much fair to Jamie as as
I say my own naivete coming from the the
simpler older days of biology in which
money really didn't come into it I mean
back before biology started interacting
so closely with medicine there wasn't a
lot of money at stake and a lot of
biologists more or less took vows of
poverty to do what they do as most
writers do and that was sort of a
comfortable comfortable very familiar
world and it felt like an innocent more
innocent world now in fact I mentioned
before the memory guys who are working
on memory are starting pharmaceutical
companies many biologists I talked to
are richer in cash than they are in in
honors yet they've received tens of
millions of dollars overnight for the
discovery of a gene that might turn out
to play a role in obesity control let's
say or might not it it does a it ethical
complexities and ambiguities and I'm
sure if you pursue these the path you're
on that will be one area you might you
you might be looking at and then there
are other things that at the time seemed
really like immediate scary
possibilities and still due to the
current bioethics Commission but that I
think have receded somewhat as concerns
I mentioned the cloning
of that lamb dolly in 97 that mood that
anything was possible brought optimism
to families like the heywoods in crisis
and it also brought fear to those who
wondered if we were about to engineer
armies of new and soulless human beings
all kinds of brave new world nightmares
arose overnight with the cloning of
Dolly and because I was hanging around
with people who were doing that kind of
research more of us off the books and
out of out of sight looking over their
shoulders as they were doing things that
on pointed in that brave new world
direction I talked a little bit about
this in the book as well um that too
covered for me the progress of Jamie's
race toward a genetic engineering of his
of his brother I had some of that brave
new world uneasiness about the whole
area of genetic engineering and although
I think those dangers are still with us
and the future of the human species now
is a part of part of our contemplation
of of Jacob's Ladder of the the ladder
of DNA now are we going up or down what
are we are we going to make changes in
DNA for for the sake of saving this
person or that person that will then
lead to changes as dramatic in our
species as say the changes in the
Galapagos and Darwin's islands are all
of that seemed more immediate back in 98
99 than it does now now that it turns
out for instance that cloning is not so
easy and that the brave new world future
that seemed upon us with the apocalyptic
year 2000 that that that isn't happening
so fast the good things we hope for the
bad things we feared are all going to
come more
incrementally than we thought then but
they remain fears and they remain
difficulties that we have to take step
by step and I think I make that pitch
for support for stem cell research in
the face of a Miss a sense of misgiving
among some people in Washington about
this kind of research that is over
heightened that is still in that almost
worried state that we were all entered
after the birth announcement of Dolly
well that's a long answer but there are
a lot of concerns here on on all sides
and you can't tell a simple story I find
when you get to the edge of Medicine yes
hi I'm max Chapman despite your
assumption I have spinal neuropathy
which is a little bit like Lou Gehrig's
but his causes not generally known it's
much slower and and often not fatal but
so I'm very much in support of gene
therapy and but the thought that I had
that might actually help I hope pray etc
is you may not need a direct gene
therapy to cure something like Lou
Gehrig's don't let me explain why you've
probably seen as many of us have on the
news they are now using plants and
insects and bacteria and all kinds of
things to modify their genes to produce
certain components and proteins that
ourselves need nowadays I would wager
that many of us are taking what they
call dietary supplements like
glucosamine and chondroitin they and
other all kinds of vitamins and things
and these are components very much like
to eat a 80 the e2 that you spoke about
my thought was why not use genetic
engineering to manufacture the e eat eat
22 the component that is called the lack
of which are of good e 2 is causing the
disease and then inject it into the
system
through the blood stream in a protein
sheet this technology is already well
understood the virus shell of something
like a rhinovirus now let me explain to
those who are not familiar with the
science what that is many of us are
taking aspirin one a day it's urged that
we all should take a baby aspirin at
least one a day for our heart however
it's been noted that many people have
stomach sensitivity to that so they have
coated aspirin that's the orange coated
aspirin and that carries it through the
stomach where it irritates it and into
the intestines in the same manner what
you do is you take the protein which is
a component of the cell that needs to be
there and you encapsulate it are coated
in a virus protein shell now these
shells are recognized by the different
cells as you know whether to take them
through the cell wall which is the
barrier so a certain type of shell a
certain type of cell like a neuron in
the spinal cord will welcome it in and
in that way you can get the good protein
in the cells where they're needed with
just normal injection into the
bloodstream instead of the dire
practices that caused this original do
you have any thoughts on it well thank
you there are many ways of administering
a drug other than gene therapy you're
quite right and I I would hesitate at
that word dire that you used at the end
gene therapy is very difficult at this
time gene therapy is under a cloud at
this time because of the death of gal
singer and because of seven several
other failures gene therapy remains a
promising way of administering a drug
but certainly not the only not the only
way and we all take many medicines uh
without undergoing gene therapy and
there are many new delivery methods that
are being developed it's um it's true
that as we understand better how our
bodies work at the level of molecules it
becomes increasingly possible to imagine
ways to correct defects or to enhance
performance not only through changing
the genes but through administering
doses of their products as drugs that
one swallows or one injects and two to
take an extreme and naive proposal from
those heady days in at the end of the
20th century a certain enzyme called
telomerase which people discovered is
involved in seems to be involved in the
cell cycle and in determining when a
cell has reached the end of its life
span um could in principle be
administered as a pill or as an
injection or perhaps through gene
therapy again this was a naive hope
things are way more complicated than
this as it turns out but could be
administered as a way of extending the
life of those cells or maybe even as
some sort of immortality pill and that
was the kind of talk that was very much
alive in the last years of the 20th
century and it's more subdued now as
biologists realized the complexities of
the systems they're talking about in
there at the level of the cell I mean
life is complicated we know it in our
daily lives and it is no simpler at the
level of the cell and so almost any
solution that is billed as a silver
bullet a magic bullet is going to turn
out to have more complexities and more
ramifications than than we imagined and
many of the magic bullets the are only
going to lead us toward a greater
understanding of the complexity inside
the cell which is again the reason why
we need huge collective effort in order
to advance in biology so I'll turn
around and come
back to that the more technical specific
parts of your of your suggestion are
interesting but there I think over over
all of our heads and it'll be
interesting to know to know more please
email me if you want to follow that up
yes um two quick things first of all I
think your are you the same author who
also wrote a book about global warming a
number yeah that's I think the one boy
did I bad and I enjoyed it tremendously
it was very good and I when I read it
and seeing the copyright date that it
was a while ago I'm surprised that I
hadn't heard more about it in recent
times but anyone anyone who's interested
in that I'd recommend it was very good
thank you that's called the next 100
years and it is out of print but it was
written but if everyone asked for it
they'll print it again yeah and
everybody asked me when can it be
reprinted right but it was written at a
time when talk about co2 and global
warming seemed almost like talking
apocalyptic talk I mean the the
scientists i was talking to worth
tremendously concerned and nobody had
heard of it nobody was talking about it
and now I you know we may be suffering
through a little a little tinge of it at
this moment I mean it's all I know it's
on our minds everywhere now the question
on on today's topic that I had is um is
Stephen Hawking still alive and if so
how how is he lives for so long with ALS
Stephen Hawking is perhaps the most
famous victim of ALS a lot today and no
one does understand why a disease that
normally kills in a matter of years has
had spared him for so long unfortunately
he was he was diagnosed in his 20s and
he's now I think in his 60s and still
going strong and I've asked Jamie
Heywood that question I've asked Jeff
Rothstein that question everybody in the
practice of medicine knows that
there are outliers in every disease
there are these outliers there are
people who fall right in the expected
pattern and then there are people way
outside it and it may be that increased
understanding of the workings of these
diseases at the molecular level help
eventually for us to know and it may be
there will be a clue there it may be
that hulking will make contributions not
only in the field of astrophysics but
here in the world of the physician at
the moment um that simply remains a
mystery well we've been given a mandate
to end there I guess we'll end there
thanks again
Jonathan Weiner is a visiting professor
in the department of molecular biology
at Princeton he won the Pulitzer Prize
for general nonfiction and the Los
Angeles Times Book Prize for science for
his book the beak of the Finch his
brother's keeper is published by echo an
imprint of harpercollins visit
HarperCollins com for more information